i had a blast with your film um and um
so i i guess i want to start with uh i
like throwing out like um
uh uh usually a curveball but with this
i sort of wanted to say what does it
mean to all of you guys because all the
reviews on this movie have been so
positive and you really never know when
you make a movie what the reaction is
going to be so what does it mean to all
three of you to have such positive
reviews yes i mean obviously it feels
wonderful that all the views are so
positive and
and
but
so for me the best part of that is that
it's really uh
uh thank for the for the great work that
our whole crew and the all the actors
have done so i'm i'm very happy about
that and i'm very happy that the reviews
have really mentioned uh
almost all the
the the elements of the film and the the
cinematography and designing and the
actors and i'm very happy about that so
it's really a
kind of award for the great work we have
done and i hope also that now this it
helps
uh
many people to
go and see the film because as filmmaker
that's uh what you want two people to
see the film
we're so surprised and we're so uh we're
so happy uh that it got this response
and
for myself i i i'm not a huge
fan of uh horror i haven't
seen or done any harm before so
so i had no idea what to expect uh you
know uh what the the audience was gonna
think about a project like this
so yeah it's amazing
that i got these reviews uh hannah i
hate asking the generic question but
most people watching this interview will
not have seen the film yet so how have
you been describing it to people
well it's a
kind of a
horror drama so it's a
horror film with a dramatic story and
it's about a
a girl who hatches a creature out of an
egg and this girl has very demanding
mother and she feels that she can't
really
be accepted fully as she is and she
starts finds a nick and starts
hatching it while she also hatches her
own emotions and something
that's very that's a good description um
so i read and i could be wrong about
this but i read that you
uh filmed this a while ago and then ifc
bought it and you've sort of been
waiting for it to come out so what what
has it been like actually waiting for it
to come out these last you know the last
two years if you will uh knowing you had
made something cool
uh well it has been really kind of the
one year it has been completed and we've
been just waiting because of the copied
so
yeah we've been waiting and waiting and
there there has been moments that not
now we can really release the film oh no
no no everything gets closed again oh no
not yet not yet not yet so
uh-huh
yes it has been a long wait and kind of
feeling that when we
ever get into cinemas we'll let people
ever see it and but now i'm super happy
because sundance was really the a kind
of priority number one the festival that
we really hoped to get the film
in and uh and so
this is kind of like
reaching the goal
one of the things that i really
enjoyed about this film one of the many
things is that i've never really seen a
movie like this it's a very original
coming-of-age film um can you sort of
talk about how it's really
unlike things that you have seen yes i
it all started from a screenwriter's
idea and he contacted me and said that
he has this one sentence idea that a boy
hatches a double ganger out of an egg
and that is all he knows so far and and
i said that that is cool but let's
change the lead character into a girl
and also my
uh
the reason why i got interested in just
this one sentence was that i also felt
that okay this is a story i haven't seen
before and this could be very cool and
so we started to develop all the themes
from this one sentence that okay if
somebody's hatching something it means
that she's hiding maybe some elements of
her character and
okay there is a theme of motherhood
there's theme of growing up
and so everything came from this one
sentence and then i really
uh
wanted to create this world that shows
the experience of this lead character
the girl and the girl's mother is a
blogger she is kind of an influential
shooting
videos of her family too for the whole
world to see and she's really portraying
her ideal of a perfect life so i wanted
to really show this
mother's universe and everything is like
lovely pastel colors and a lot of roses
and always kind of quite bright light
even the night is kind of a nordic light
night so there are no dark shadows
because there are no dark secrets or so
you would sink
[Laughter]
um siri uh this this is for you um this
was your first
movie your first acting role
what do you wish you knew on the first
day of filming that you now know
well she said that at first
on the first day she was thinking that
about the every people on the set and
she was kind of very aware that they are
all looking at her and she was very
nervous and then after a couple of days
she got used to it and understood that
she can just relax and everybody on set
is professionals and doing their work
and they are
used to actors so to speak and so then
she could really relax and just
concentrate on the party
uh hannah this film does not work unless
you find the right person to inhabit the
role i mean uh and i'm just curious i
read could be wrong that you saw 1200
girls
uh to for this role and i'm just curious
what was it about siri that said oh this
is this is the person this is for i want
her
yeah yes so
really because i mean everything in this
film depends on this lead character was
double lead character in this film and i
to be honest i've never seen so
demanding role for 12 year old child in
any film before and yeah so that's why
we origin 1200 girls and and series and
then self tape at first
and so
i know i i wrote comments for every self
tape and i wrote yes if i want that
person to come to the audition and now i
checked my old
comments and i wrote kind of big
yes to her
it was
really about her just being so
so natural
in front of the camera and and then
there was a
thing that she had to do was to kind of
imagine that she's very
angry and just scream on top of her
lungs and and she she really screamed
and and then after screaming she started
to
kind of just stay down and watched the
camera lens like that and i was like wow
she's so good
for siri and for sofia uh what was it
like actually reading the script for the
first time
and seeing what this film was going to
ask of you and what it was about
well when i first heard about the movie
i i i've told hannah this i honestly
thought it was some sort of joke or or
maybe like a student project or
something because i'd never seen
anything like this and and
so i was very skeptical when i read the
script but then i did and i was
so amazed that you could
combine horror with
really heavy themes
like like they did in this
movie and so i was just super
relieved and uh and amazed really really
impressed
yeah she was just thinking while she was
reading the script that it she thought
that it's very good script and very kind
of uh scary and she was already uh
and that was kind of good things you
thought and
he was already scared when she read the
script
one of the things that i found uh really
cool about the movie again one of the
many things sophia your character is
more obsessed with social media
than your soon-to-be teenage daughter uh
and i i think that the film does a
really good job talking about social
media without you know hitting you over
the head uh can you sort of talk about
um
the social media aspect of your
character yeah
well another uh
thing that that hit me when i read the
script for the first time was like has
someone told me what kind of mother i am
because there were even though i i don't
identify myself with her
uh 100 i could find these
qualities that that i could relate to
which is really sad to say but i'm very
active uh on social media and sometimes
uh
maybe
spend too little time in the weekend
with my kids because i'm you know on
social media and i really hate that
and um
so
yeah it's totally relatable i think and
all over the world it's just not just a
finnish thing
i think everyone can relate
relate to that and i've been going
over it in my head you know i think
i think parents i mean obviously this
mother it's it's um we've taken it up a
notch but i think parents of all time
have always had somewhere to escape
either a magazine or a book or you know
whatever and and social media is just
our way to
um
to to flee into another reality for for
a while i'm i'm the mother of three so
um
so yeah i kind of i really relate to her
in one way
and uh
at the same time i hope i'm not that
horrible
in real life
um hannah can you sort of talk about why
you wanted to sort of add social media
and it's sort of like a commentary uh
that you've added to the film which i
really appreciated
yeah
the social media aspect wasn't in a kind
of first script version and but the
whole theme was about these people who
are trying to
keep up appearance in one way of them
being perfect happy family and then i
started to think that what is
today's way of kind of showing to
everybody that we are happy we are happy
everything's fine in our family and that
is really social media so then i really
wanted to get this
uh social media theme into this film and
then with that
i think everything really started to
come alive because it is really
today's
way of kind of
keeping up the front
well
absolutely um
one of the things is this creature that
you have in the movie uh it needs to
work you need to believe in it or else
this whole thing falls apart so hannah
can you sort of talk about how you
wanted to design the creature and what
you were looking for to depict on film
uh yes and that was super important
because uh if the creature doesn't work
the whole film doesn't work so
uh and and from the very early on i
didn't want it to be a cg character
because i wanted it to have real
physical presence so i thought that when
it's it's in the most when it first had
cheese i wanted it to be
an animatronic puppet kind of like e.t
and some star wars creatures have been
meaning that it's a puppet that's facial
remove uh expressions moving remote
control so so i knew that i needed the
best possible person to
create this puppet so i basically i
googled best animatronic designer in the
world
google told me that okay that is gustav
hergen who has been the lead animatronic
designer in star wars films and jurassic
world and prometheus and so on and i
thought that well he's pretty good and
uh and then i contacted him and uh he
had just finished the
the last star wars films and uh he got
excited about the story and wanted to
come on board and his fantastic team
uh builded this puppet that we had
designed in finland with two wonderful
concept artists uh petri makin and
emilia lindholm so
yeah and then we had this uh
amazing five puppeteers so at the
shootings there were five people moving
the puppet with the rods and they were
all super pros they have been working in
all star wars films and there was gustav
hergen uh uh moving the facial
expressions with the remote control so
there's a lot going on at the shootings
and and uh
and i'm super happy with the result and
the puppeteers really made the puppet
act so well and that is how it became so
kind of alive and relatable i think
i find it so fascinating that you were
able to you know sometimes people say
the internet's bad uh or you know but i
find it fascinating that you basically
googled best animatronic person and
you're like yeah let's just hire you
know what i mean like it connects the
world yeah yeah
it's that's amazing actually um what was
it listen you guys obviously made this
on a budget and you had a i'm sure you
know this was not a marvel movie um and
i'm just curious what was what ended up
being the toughest stuff to pull off uh
with the time and the budget that you
had
and this applies to everybody
well i think in the end of course all
these special effects and everything
that that is because it's the biggest
thing but maybe in the end in every
filmmaking
the most important thing is the time in
the shooting so so norma we had more
time well we had about 40 shooting days
which is more than in the usual finnish
films because we make films in very low
budget and uh but still because we had
all these special effects and uh in some
days he had this uh special effect
makeup that took like four hours to put
on and take off so we had like four
hours time to shoot her she's basically
in every shot so
so
i think always in the film making the
most important thing is the time in the
shootings and the time with the actors
and that is always too little no matter
what you do and siri and sophia did you
guys feel any sort of uh pressure
because you know you're trying to do so
much in a short period of time or did
you sort of was it a very relaxing shoot
i must say it felt really luxurious um
this was a very big budget for finnish
film uh the most expensive movie ever
directed by a woman in finland actually
so uh
so yeah i
i really felt we had a lot of days
shooting days compared to what you
usually have and we had time to rehearse
we had time to get to know each other cd
and me which is uh amazing that never
happens in finland uh well very seldom
so so i was very happy
the only
the only thing that bugged me was the
last day where there was a lot to be
shot and we we shot the last scene the
last day and i
i would have liked two more two more
shots of that but you know that's the
only thing i really i'm and and hannah
kept um
uh even though i knew we were in a hurry
uh hannah kept a really
peaceful atmosphere and
yeah it was it was very nice to work
with yeah
siri i have to ask you there are some
shots where you are in some pretty cool
makeup did you ever beg to leave set and
go to like a supermarket wearing that
makeup
she said at one point i didn't know that
she said at one point at the one
shooting day she actually uh she had a
break so she went and walked on the
street
with that baby
she said
somebody saw her
wondered a bit but
that that uh i always if uh i talk to a
lot of actors and i talk to a lot of
people and often they're in extreme
costumes or extreme makeup and if i ever
did that i would absolutely go to the
starbucks and walk around and freak
people out like it's halloween
[Laughter]
you know um i i'm i love talking about
the editing process because that's where
the movie comes together so hannah could
you sort of talk about um when you got
in the editing room were you at first
ready to jump through a window or were
you like oh we have it
ah
yeah that is a good question well i i
always like in the editing that the the
editor we had a wonderful swedish editor
linda ildman so i always like uh that
the editor first uh does her own version
so we have first talked about the the
film and the scenes and then she just
does her version
so it gives me a
kind of a
new start in a way so that i can just
watch the material okay this is what we
have
and the first version was very long it
was like two hours long because
everything was kind of there but but
like you said usually there is this
feeling oh my god
i'm gonna die nothing works but in this
case
no i already that yeah yeah it will be a
good movie there's a lot of work to be
done but but it's
i was already quite happy about it and
then it was really just
uh finding the right rhythm and some
couple of scenes or one big scene we
actually cut out of the film in the
editing process and because
that film was more focused on the father
and son and that was something we
realized
with the editor linda that in the
editing that we really need to focus
even more on the story of mother and
daughter because that's how the
that's what makes the film work
uh without going into any spoilers uh
the third act has some stuff that must
have been hard to film and i'm just
curious what was it like on set filming
some of those sequences
yes that was uh that required a
huge planning and ev every shot was kind
of scheduled and planned beforehand
because there was a
uh
[Music]
theory playing kind of two roles and
there was body doubles and there was
blood all over and all these continuity
issues and different kind of knives and
uh some vfx sorts we had wonderful vfx
company media and uh
and uh so there was kind of a lot going
on and all the special effects makeup we
had wonderful special effects makeup
designer conor sullivan these two time
was condemnated on uh setting private
ryan at the dark knight and his
wonderful team created this special pack
makeup so
yes there was a lot going on that was
really i'm very glad to hear that there
was relaxed atmosphere because in my
mind i was kind of like oh i'm counting
the minute that oh my god will we get it
done and we have only this day
time to shoot with this huge makeup and
so yes but we got it done
uh sophia and siri uh can you sort of
talk about though filming with the
makeup and that stuff in the third act
and did you enjoy filming that stuff you
know or um uh i i'm just curious if you
enjoyed especially siri with some of
that makeup did you enjoy filming with
that kind of stuff
yeah she said the final scene she
thought were the most fun and uh and
also the best scenes in the film so
she thinks and the beak actually in the
very end otherwise we had mostly just
practical effects but in the very end
there's a big
thing in her head so so that was a a
complete cg look
yeah the
that bit was definitely the most
technical bit um and the least scary bit
to film because as hannah said uh there
was so much uh done afterwards
so um it was definitely a lot of fun and
some stunts also uh in there so um yeah
i really enjoyed them
uh hannah can you talk a little bit
about the production design and how you
decided on the way the house was going
to look and also the fact that there's
like no newspapers there's no outside
world you're sort of isolated if you
will with uh it's an isolating kind of a
thing
yes
that was something i really wanted to
reach with this film this kind of world
that it's not it's not totally fairy
tale it sounds like tim burton type of
film and it's it's kind of reality but
there's something off so i really really
wanted to find this uncanny valley i
think it's the word kind of uh this fine
line between fairy tale and uh reality
and to kind of make people unease
a bit and uh
so we talked with a production designer
by the cattlemen that
that first of all i talked about this
pastel colors that i want to have in
this film and and also
that she asked that do you think that
there are some newspapers like you said
in this world and i said that no no
newspapers no logos
uh nothing can relate to some particular
era or country so really we took out
every
every possible logo every possible text
every newspaper and even there's a pet
shop so we made all these uh
uh
pitch of foods so that they are just for
this field amanda and uh and for example
then there are all these kind of details
that you never see other people in the
street
and uh
there's a hospital so there's nobody at
the hospital so it's because i really
wanted to tell
uh about genius life that in her life
there's nothing else except what mother
wants her to do
uh the
house and then the gymnast and even the
gymnast hall we don't really see that
much the other girls we just hear them
laughing that was wonderful idea from
our
sound designer carlos vinson that what
we hear is the laughter of other girls
so they are kind of having fun for them
it's a kind of fun
uh hobby and for dinner it's just
concentrating on the kind of doing the
tricks doing the tricks and the
succeeding sundance interviews are
interesting because
i i love talking about the movie but i
can't really get into the specifics
because you don't want to ruin it for
the people that haven't watched it yet
it's like a tricky kind of interview if
that makes any sense you know um
my um my last question for all for you
guys i love learning about the behind
the scenes of the making of a movie so
for all three of you
what is something that you think people
would be surprised to learn about the
making of the movie or what's like a fun
day on set that you'd like to share well
i can say i can say one thing that is
nice i i one well of course it was cool
to sort this animatoric puppet and also
one another kind of fun thing was to
shoot with the real bird because in the
beginning of the film there's a bird
flying
in the living room and that was actually
a a real bird but the bird has lived all
his uh it's life in a cage so he didn't
really like to fly so that's how
the animal owner kind of always tossed
it so it kind of flew with a little bit
no birds were harmed but so it was
really ahead of the animal owner tossing
it around and it's just flying a little
bit and then it started to run away and
the animal owner
did that was
a lot going on that day in the shooting
but it was a lot of fun and the bird was
super cute
um there were a lot of fun fun things um
there was one scene without giving
anything away um i'm in the car and
there is a bit of blood
involved um so we needed to squirt some
blood into my nose but i also had a line
and what we didn't realize is when you
squirt a lot of blood into your nose it
goes to your
throat
so and and we had like two shots because
i had this dress and we couldn't uh mess
it up too much because i only could
change once um
so yeah i have this blood coming out of
every
hole in my face but i wasn't able to
speak at all
so uh well it ended up pretty pretty
good
uh that shot anyway but but it was fun
because it was just so messy and we
couldn't really rehearse it uh
beforehand
that that shot turns out well
good
yeah
uh siri do you have anything
oh
oh yes so that was um
because she had never acted before
anywhere before this film and uh so in
the film we had the first uh scene where
she had to we were shooting in a car she
had to cry
and uh so we were about to give her some
this um mental you know drops that you
put in the eyes to get the tears come
out
and uh and then she was just thinking
that no no i want to do this real and
but how do i do it and then we it was
just that we were just about to put the
drops in her eyes and then she said that
no stop no i can't i can do it for real
and then she just concentrated and
started to cry and uh and after that it
was really because
she has to cry in many scenes so so it
was for me it was basically just that
okay you see it and now you cry again
and then she was just okay okay i take a
minute okay now i'm ready and that is
just starting to cry that was amazing
i uh i definitely could not do that and
i say congratulations for being able to
pull that off um i'm gonna stop here and
just say uh sincerely congratulations on
this movie i'm very happy for you guys
and i'm very happy for the positive
reviews and um i wish you guys nothing
but the best and thank you for talking
with me about the film
thank you so much
you